en 2018 vous avez vu clé de l'écart 1 en
2019 vous avez vu que le Dolly car 2 en
2020 vous avez vu alerte coronavirus
après deux ans d'attente nous avons
enfin pu réaliser l'épisode 3 de
claudelica le endgame des meurtres ont
été commis et le coupable est forcément
l'un des joueurs de cette nouvelle vidéo
et cette vidéo elle célèbre également
les deux millions d'abonnés merci pour
ça c'est comme toujours c'est incroyable
au tout début je pensais même pas qu'on
pourrait être cent mille à se retrouver
ici et c'est à dire qu'à divers moments
se dire il y a eu 2 millions de
personnes qui ont cliqué sur le gros
bouton rouge ça fait quelque chose pour
la fin de cette trilogie il y aura pas
quatre joueurs comme d'habitude dans les
clés de l'Icare mais 8 mais évidemment
nous avons un casting parfait avec Doc
seven pierre Croce Charlie danger Elisa
du groupe l.j Franck Bruce et Cyril MP4
Margot des astuces de Margaux et Daniel
le Russe ce dernier clou de l'Icare
c'est une Murder Party c'est-à-dire
c'est un jeu de rôle grandeur nature où
chaque joueur va incarner un personnage
qu'à sa vraie vie ses propres objectifs
tous mes invités ont reçu il y a
quelques semaines une fiche de
personnage qui inclut qu'ils sont quels
sont leurs objectifs leur talents
particuliers et au moment où on commence
la vidéo ils sont tous renfermés chez
YouTube où ils étaient au moment du
dernier meurtre et ils sont surveillés
par un commissaire
le commissaire ce sifflent un
commissaire qui se laisse facilement
courir ils vont mener l'enquête ils vont
protéger leur secret ils vont effectuer
des actions spéciales avec la monnaie du
jeu c'est ça ce sont des points d'action
ça vaut 100000 €, il y a ma tête dessus
donc c'est que c'est vrai le scénario
est une réadaptation du très difficile
cinq cadavre à la Une de Thibault Beguin
et Benoît Clerc auquel j'avais pu jouer
moi-même en 1995 et pour que vous
puissiez plonger dans ce club de l'Icare
voici ce que les joueurs ont reçu la
veille de la partie
depuis quelques années des personnes
disparaissent mystérieusement de la
plateforme Youtube
selon YouTube justement ces personnes se
retiraient volontairement du YouTube
game portant au sein de la communauté
notre version des faits
on avait bien essayé d'étouffer
l'affaire mais évidemment ça a fuité
alors voici la véritable version des
faits dans un très court laps de temps
quatre créateurs et créatrices de vidéos
se sont fait sauvagement assassinés
Julien fitcher ma GIF et y maxberg et
NAD for selon la très fiable chaîne
d'info Ludo t'explique la même arme un
véritable 9 mm aurait servi à assassiné
trois créateurs d'une balle dans la tête
et le quatrième d'une balle dans le dos
un autre détail macabre qu'on a réussi à
contenir avec la plateforme c'est que le
poids des quatre victimes a été retiré
par le ou les meurtriers aujourd'hui a
eu lieu un cinquième assassinat pour des
raisons inconnues le vidéaste chaud
entier quitte son domicile et se rend
ici même au centre des réunions de
YouTube après avoir semé les policiers
chargés de sa protection c'est ici dans
l'ascenseur du parking de YouTube qui
est assassiné j'ai fait boucler les
lieux l'assassin ne peut être que l'une
des 8 personnes présentes sur place au
moment du crime ce soir il se trouvait
les 8 quelque part à l'intérieur de
l'immeuble qui sert de bureau YouTube et
c'est à 21h55 très précisément que
Adrien sens découvre dans un des
ascenseurs de l'immeuble le cadavre
encore chaud de chaud entier le vidéaste
il a reçu une balle dans la tête une
plaie B entre révèle ses entrailles le
foie a été arraché à 21h56 j'arrive dans
les locaux je fais boucler le périmètre
en moins d'une demi-heure l'immeuble est
fouillé de fond en comble par tous les
policiers mais même toutes les personnes
qui te trouvent dans les locaux mais les
gardiens huit personnes se trouvaient
donc sur place au moment du crime en
dépit des protestations indignés des
menaces que j'ai pu recevoir je les ai
tous rassemblés tous les 8 à l'étage
supérieur où se trouve la garçonnière de
alphabet le patron tout puissant du
groupe fabett et donc de Youtube je sais
que le meurtrier de chaud entier et des
quatre autres vidéastes et l'un d'entre
eux et personne écoutez-moi personne ne
quittera l'immeuble avant que je ne
sache lequel par contre je vais les
autoriser à mener leur petit enquête sur
les lieux sous mon contrôle mais
interdiction d'avoir un contact avec
l'extérieur un article de presse résume
très bien les événements de ces deux
dernières années vous allez pouvoir le
lire maintenant en faisant pause ou le
télécharger dans la description il vous
donnera exactement la même connaissance
que les 8 joueurs avaient au début de la
partie sur ces meurtres vous pouvez
aussi décider d'assister à l'accueil des
suspects et découvrir qui sont ces 8
personnes tout au long de la vidéo je
reviendrai pour vous donner les secrets
les objectifs de chacun afin que vous
ayez parfois un coup d'avance sur les
joueurs et mieux apprécier ce qu'il se
trame aucune de vos questions ne sera
laissée sans réponse ils sont 8 ils ont
trois heures pour se discuter atteindre
leurs objectifs personnels et cacher
leur secret bienvenue dans le troisième
épisode de clé de Lucas
22h30 moi je pourrai pas protéger votre
réputation trop longtemps il va falloir
que la presse s'empare de tout ça parce
que va falloir que je divulgue des
informations je vous garde encore
quelques heures mais demain matin tout
sort dans la presse donc vous
débrouillez comme vous voulez vous me
dites quel coupable vous le trouvez ou
nous on trouvera votre place et ça va
pas être bon pour les histoires juste
avant de vous laisser faire sachez que
je resterai dans le coin ce que je vais
mener ma propre enquête vous
stressez-vous non mais c'est bien que ça
je vois que c'est à nous de faire le
boulot quoi c'est cool pour ceux qui me
connaissent pas encore c'est que vous
lisez pas la presse je suis le
commissaire social et j'ai déjà commencé
par fouiller un petit peu les boîtes aux
lettres pour voir qui recevais quoi ici
j'ai du courrier pour vous
du courrier personnel apparemment
[Musique]
Adrien sens levait la main
votre grand-mère c'est officierac très
étrange que vous recevez du courrier ici
Mélissa
et Monsieur fabette du groupe fabette
lorsque vous faites bon ben je vous
laisse si vous avez besoin de moi je
suis là il y a également une stagiaire
avec moi une Benji que vous pouvez aller
voir c'est parti
belle soirée belle soirée monsieur belle
soirée pour parler oh c'est peut-être
pas le moment on a quelque chose à se
dire je bois vraiment il y a quelqu'un
qui est morte on peut voir ça plus tard
non je ne pense pas je pense vous pouvez
déjà devant tout le monde
à 21h30 on travaille
chez moi donc on va essayer de trouver
des choses parce que là
je vais faire un tour
[Musique]
elle est à la fois inspecteur du FBI
spécialisé dans la lutte contre les
céréales killer et agent de la CIA ou
plutôt elle était parce qu'elle a été
mise à la peur des deux institutions il
y a 15 jours depuis plusieurs mois elle
enquêtait sur un dossier très sensible
qui concernait un agent double français
particulièrement trouble Jean-Paul bien
joué Joe la CIA soupçonné bien joué Joe
d'être un argent triple et même au
quadruple les recherches de mcfirlines
lui ont permis d'établir qu'il existait
un lien entre bien joué Joe agent de la
DGSE le gourouson un gourou tout
puissant de la secte Sun et YouTube la
plateforme nombre de vidéos elle a
clairement établi que YouTube et plus
généralement le groupe fabett
blanchissait de l'argent sale de ce
réseau notamment grâce au casino en
ligne que possède le groupe maintenant
je vais vous révéler ce qu'elle faisait
exactement le soir du meurtre elle est
rentrée par effraction dans les locaux
de YouTube dans le but de fouiller les
bureaux et de découvrir la nature exacte
des liens qui nissent YouTube à bien
jouer de Joe et à Sun le moment était
mal choisi puisque les locaux ont été
entièrement bouclés après le meurtre de
chou entier la tenté de prendre la fuite
mais mes hommes et moi nous lui avons
mis le grappin dessus alors elle a joué
la carte coopération policière elle a
annoncé qu'elle était sur la piste de
l'assassin je crois pas une seconde ce
mensonge ne l'a pas empêché d'être
emmené avec les autres suspects dans la
garçonnière de fabette mais bon après
tout c'est un bon endroit pour
poursuivre son enquête on verra ce qu'il
ressort ces objectifs personnels pour la
soirée sont les suivants elle doit
découvrir ce qui relie Sun YouTube et le
groupe Fab est en général a bien joué le
jeu elle doit trouver l'assassin des
youtubeurs avant moi ça c'est une
question d'honneur pour elle et son but
dans la vie d'une manière générale c'est
de montrer à tout le monde que les
américains sont meilleurs que les
frenchies et que tout le monde d'une
manière générale de toute façon comme
dirait Marx
faut qu'on travaille en équipe et à mes
camarades on doit absolument travailler
soud
er nous sommes tous frères et soeurs
dans cette aventure et la concrètement
doit s'en sortir comme le disait l'exode
le principaux des peuples apportent les
pierres de Nicks et d'autres pierres
pour la gagner de l'époque et du
pectoral ça vous parle à tous et je le
comprends ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que là concrètement nous devons
fonctionner en équipe en cohésion donc
je propose que tous les indices que nous
pouvons trouver nous les partageons
puisque c'est ça au final une communauté
vous allez partager votre compte en
banque aussi à leur donnez moi quelques
billets allez partageons
que par la Bible et par le marxisme pour
elle tous les moyens sont bons pour
protéger les plus faibles c'est le but
dans sa vie et je reviendrai un petit
peu plus tard sur son histoire complète
ils ont moins la vie c'est le business
et pour faire du business il y a pas
besoin de tuer les gens je préfère tuer
et communiquement que tu es prendre une
vie je comprends c'est pas oui pour toi
c'est oui non
[Musique]
pour ceux qui ont connu Bernard Tapie on
est exactement sur le même genre de
caractère c'est un self maidman très
médiatique de l'économie française il
est parvenu récemment à pénétrer
massivement le capital de YouTube en
plus de ses activités industrielles il
est également député émergé les
maastrichtiens pour la résurrection du
général et président d'un club de foot
l'Olympique de Montélimar il fait un peu
de tout il est dans tous les business je
reviendrai sur lui tout à l'heure
monsieur Léo si vous faites là c'est
marrant ça on a quelque chose à régler
je crois
vous avez pas honte vous n'avez pas
de parole ballon
monsieur
sénateurs
ah le cul du Président il est bien
propre et les torchons s'il te plaît
est-ce que tu m'as volé ça va te retombé
sur le nez mon petit gars ici c'est chez
moi j'ai les contacts j'ai des infos sur
toi donc fais attention
la vengeance
[Musique]
Adrien sens surnommé AdSense c'est le
responsable de la monétisation il a mené
pendant très longtemps une carrière
politique notamment comme sénateur il
est également le président d'un club de
foot le Vierzon atlantique il travaille
pour YouTube mais aussi sur jupe de
l'état car il doit garder une
déontologie sur la plateforme c'est le
but dans son histoire perso il est fils
unique d'une riche dynastie de personnes
qui ont investi très tôt dans la tech
dans les Minitel principalement
il a donc hérité d'une immense fortune
parce qu'ils ont vendu à temps et c'est
justement avec cet argent qui l'a monté
algorithme mon ami une petite start-up
qui a connu un certain succès et qui a
été vite racheté par alphabet mais
quelques années qu'il a passé à la tête
de sa start-up quand on permet
d'acquérir une certaine réputation
locale qui a décidé de mettre à profit
pour se lancer dans la politique il a
été eu sénateur donc sous l'étiquette em
évitant le mauvais il s'est toujours
intéressé aux problèmes des médias en
France et c'est donc naturellement qu'à
la fin de son second mandat il a accepté
de devenir le Président du Comité de
monétisation de YouTube on peut le dire
si la plateforme aujourd'hui gagne
beaucoup d'argent c'est en grande partie
à lui qu'elle le doit sa technique était
très simple rendre invisible vidéo qui
ne sont pas du cœur divertissement
simple pour mettre en avant des
vidéastes vedettes qui répondent plus
docilement aux critères des annonceurs
alors bien sûr ça lui avait lu quelques
rancune dans le milieu et le
franchissement de quelques lignes
éthiques ou légales mais bon hein comme
il dit on fait pas d'omelette sans
casser des oeufs
très peu de temps
la pizza
écoutez je vais être honnête avec vous
ma petite dame
donnez-moi votre main
je peux vous faire confiance
il y a la présence d'une
je pense qu'elle est peut-être impliquée
dans ses crimes à savoir que le chef de
la secte aurait un tatouage sur
l'avant-bras un as de pique je peux
voir une secte oui
a compris ça n'était pas un hasard tout
à l'heure je vous expliquais que MCF
airlane était à la recherche d'un gourou
un gourou aussi influent que mystérieux
appelé scène qui œuvre dans des deals
pas très clairs et qui semble avoir des
contacts chez les puissants de ce monde
personne n'a jamais vu son visage mais
il a été remarqué qu'il avait un NAS de
pique tatoué sur l'avant-bras droit le
fait que le gourou possède un as de
pique sur l'avant-bras droit leur fera
peut-être faire un lien avec un autre
article présent dans la garçonnière que
personne n'a lu pour le moment cet
article explique que de riches
industrielles et autres mafieux se
réunissent pour des parties de poker
remise parfois étrange et abusé parce
que les membres de ce cercle de poker
pour riche et puissance se reconnaissent
avec un as de pique tatoué sur
l'avant-bras
comment vous savez vous avez des beaux
comment vous savez
rien du tout
se manipulateur c'est le vermine le
crapaud
il est toujours tranquille dans pas mal
d'histoires chez nous
allez voir s'il traînerait pas avec une
secte le seul regardez c'est
bon
moi j'ai rien à cacher moi j'ai rien à
cacher moi
je n'ai rien à cacher
Sophie kirak non Sophie n'est pas
vraiment une livreuse de pizza étudiante
au service départements sciences et
technologique du futur du pôle
universitaire de webedia salée
spécialisée dans la tech dans le cadre
de ces études sur les ondes
anti-protoniques à Rayonnement nucléaire
à la découverte qu'elles étaient émises
par les démons oui des ponts mais qui
croient vraiment au démon franchement
c'est le quelques-uns de ses proches
amis ou accepté de se rendre à
l'évidence les démons existent tout
comme il y a un moyen scientifique de
les repérer avec eux à la montée une
organisation secrète qui s'appelle le
doom le département d'opposition aux
offenses maléfiques l'objectif ce
qu'elle s'est fixé est simple et
radicale détecter les démons et les
éliminer récemment repéré une émission
d'onde antiprotonique à Rayonnement
nucléaire de force 9 sur l'échelle
d'activité maléfique qui comporte
seulement 10 échelons donc c'est
beaucoup ça ramène à se concentre sur
l'immeuble des bureaux de YouTube mais
jusqu'à présent elle n'est pas parvenue
à identifier précisément la personne qui
aimait les ondes le doom a donc décidé
d'organiser une expédition le secret
dans les locaux de YouTube pour
découvrir l'identité du démon qui s'y
cache qu'a-t-elle fait ce soir ce soir à
21h43 elle rentre chez YouTube en se
faisant passer pour une livreuse de
pizza armée de son détecteur à ondes
anti-protonique elles fonce vers les
pièces d'où proviennent les plus fortes
radiations elle approche du but lorsque
brusquement le flux anti-protonique se
brouille après quelques manipulations
elle parvient à repérer une nouvelle
émission qui vient d'ailleurs elle se
lance dans cette direction mais la
police tombe sur elle et je lui apprends
la mort de chantier elle a tenté de
m'échapper mais cette tentative c'est
soldée par un échec un bon gros coup de
matraque sur la tête heureusement elle
partait encore sans casque je ne l'ai
pas fait de mal ces objectifs de ce soir
personnels sont de se disculper du
meurtre de chou entier afin d'être
innocenté de découvrir l'identité du
démon qui est parmi eux et bien sûr de
l'éliminer grâce à son crucifix à
Rayonnement positronique et enfin de
maintenir sa couverture de livreuse de
pizza
[Musique]
vous avez besoin de moi vous avez pas eu
besoin de moi ces dernières années pour
faire vos magouilles non vous êtes tous
des magouilles
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans votre
bureau
comme quoi j'ai rien à me cacher
une petite chose quand même oui mais bon
tes photos de vacances
[Musique]
est actuellement directeur d'un Network
qui gère plusieurs chaînes pour Youtube
pour lui c'est l'aboutissement d'une
très longue carrière au corps de
laquelle il a gravi à peu près tous les
échelons de la profession toujours au
service des médias du groupe fabett il a
d'abord travaillé pour Google j'ai des
mails etc c'est ainsi que alphabet a
fait appel à lui pour prendre les
commandes d'un network de YouTube qui
veut en réalité garder l'image publique
de ne pas intervenir dans le contenu des
créateurs au coco d'animation a toujours
employé tous les moyens possibles pour
écraser les autres et se faire valoir
délation ou monter chantage compte au
nombre de ces techniques favorites ça
force professionnelle tient dans sa
conception visionnaire de contenu
moderne pour la plateforme tout entier
tourné vers la recherche du sensationnel
au détriment du périodique la vérité
n'intéresse personne est compliquée
ennuyeuse et longue à expliquer selon
lui il a d'ailleurs poussé cette logique
jusqu'au bout en montant secrètement une
société de production de SNEF movie
appelé TDR très dur et révoltant je vois
quelques secondes dessus c'est très
important les snuff movies ce sont des
films vidéos je vous propose des
violences de torture un public averti
l'originalité de TDR tient au fait que
les victimes sont des personnes qui
l'achètent au gourou Sun le gourou tout
puissant de la secte Sun dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure et que ces
personnes subissent réellement les
sévices filmées bien évidemment ces
films sont totalement illégaux et sont
complètement immoraux la vague de crime
touchant les vidéastes vedettes de la
plateforme a d'abord été un choc
terrible pour d’alimentation mais très
rapidement il s'est aperçu que c'est
meurtres avaient un impact considérable
sur les vues les vidéos larmoyantes
présentant les deux premiers morts comme
des martyrs de la libre création sur
Internet battez tous les records de vue
il a donc décidé de faire mousser
l'affaire le plus longtemps possible
d'abord il a organisé la protection très
médiatisée des autres vidéastes
importantes la plateforme puis en
donnant un petit coup de pouce à
l'assassin après avoir diffusé la vidéo
amateur du meurtre de Julien envoyé
anonymment à son bureau et vu le succès
de cette vidéo il a décidé de recréer
les autres meurtres le Deep fake fait
des miracles il a un site déjà diffusé
le meurtre constitué de Maggie fait y
est en train de préparer le film
présentant l'assassinat de maxburg un
autre secret le relie à une autre
personne présente ce soir je vous en
parlerai plus tard en tout cas ce soir
réellement il a passé la soirée dans sa
salle de projection privée qui se trouve
à côté de son bureau pour visionner les
rush de la vidéo reconstituant la mort
de Max beurk c'est là que mes équipes et
moi-même l'avons trouvé et nous lui
avons annoncé la mort de chou entier
heureusement pour lui il a eu le temps
d'arrêter la vidéo avant que nous
arrivions dans la pièce mais la carte SD
est toujours sur place ces objectifs
personnels pour ce soir sont de faire en
sorte que personne ne découvre qu'il est
le patron des films TDR évidemment il
doit aussi attirer les soupçons sur
juste un risque et enfin il doit aider
wildeo à prendre la place de alphabet
l'idée est de négocier son appui à
wildeo contre sa nomination personnelle
au poste de directeur de YouTube
[Applaudissements]
est en business avec wildeo pour
organiser une reprise agressive de toute
l'entreprise YouTube et dans ces cas-là
vous êtes sur la sellette puisque la
dimension veut votre poste clairement et
en ce qui concerne les meurtres bon
[Musique]
je me demande si c'est pas ça
effectivement c'est particulièrement
scandaleux et particulièrement pratique
pour faire baisser l'activité de la
plateforme et sa réputation
OK et bien
je pense qu'avec 100.000 euros je peux
vous laisser fouiller
ou pas c'est déjà discuté ou vous voyez
du coup
en quelques secondes donc pour moi
le fait que tu me parles comme ça
maintenant c'était pas comme ça
donc je peux plus acheter d'action juste
parce qu'il y a un meurtre qui c'est qui
a besoin d'un meurtre ici est-ce que je
peux vous voir pendant quelques secondes
tu l'enlève 2 secondes bon regardez
c'est très bien ça va se finir ça cette
histoire et demain matin
tout le monde le sort
je vous laisse 30 secondes en fouiller
après les gens vont se rendre compte de
quelque chose
laissez-moi vous présenter juste un
risque le directeur de YouTube France
qu'on appelle en général monsieur 50% à
cause de sa petite spécialité qui est le
dégraissage de personnel les gains
productivité et la suppression de chaîne
Youtube dont le contenu ne lui plaît pas
à lui ou aux annonceurs ne reviendrons
sur son histoire et sur ses objectifs
personnels un petit peu plus tard
faisant plaisir de faire des effets avec
vous monsieur risque
vous avez une agence
dans notre bureau comment ça la vermine
le respectez-le un petit peu s'il vous
plaît
vous allez perdre votre poste monsieur
je suis honnête avec vous je dois vous
le dire moi je suis de votre côté vous
savez bien oui bien sûr je suis venu
ces histoires de crime ces achats
d'action ce timing en fait très
attention à ces gens-là si vous voulez
ensemble on peut peut-être réussir aussi
aller planter imaginer imaginez
vous rachetez vous rachetez les actions
mais comment comment le comment la
cuisiner avançons dans la même direction
quelle base trouvons des pistes trouvez
pas qu'il est un petit peu stressé très
stressé il suit du crâne il est mouillé
comme jamais très très énergique dans
son attitude un peu trop je lui dis il y
a rien qui vaille il est là le puissant
patron du groupe fabette alphabet
actionnaire majoritaire de YouTube et
patron entre autres d'une ribambelle de
société l'une des plus grandes
personnalités de l'économie française on
sait pas grand chose sur alphabet qui
préfère contrôler les médias dans
l'ombre plutôt que d'y apparaître on
reviendra tout à l'heure sur son
histoire un peu plus tard dans la soirée
vous aimez les montres
oui bien sûr
j'ai pas de monde pour vous j'ai pas de
nom
attendez s'il vous plaît le commissariat
m'appelle ceci fleurs
vous avez reçu quel document les
empreintes
ah les dernières empreintes c'est le qui
ont été relevé sur le meurtre qui a eu
quelques heures là sur le meurtre de
chou entier donc on a toutes les
empreintes vous les mettez sur le
fichier de la police sur le fichier
informatique c'est très bien alors vous
m'appelez vous savez pas où les mettre
c'est quand même toujours le même
procédure vous relevez des empreintes
vous le mettez sur le fichier central
informatique et bien noté allez je vous
remercie tropion concrètement ça veut
dire que tous les joueurs peuvent
accéder aux archives informatiques de
YouTube ainsi que dossier du personnel
certains joueurs ont des compétences
supplémentaires pour pirater les
fichiers de la police c'est bien sûr le
cas de Sophie l'ensemble des joueurs
peuvent d'ailleurs fouiller toutes les
pièces du bâtiment pour y trouver des
indices un seul indice par fouille même
s'il y a plusieurs indices par pièce
enfin il possède tous des dons ou des
talents bien spécifiques certains savent
faire du beat pocket d'autres détecter
le mensonge d'autres encore peuvent
manipuler l'esprit des autres joueurs on
en parlera tout à l'heure toutes ces
actions sont réalisables en
voyant il y a une grille de prix
préétablie la monnaie je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure s'appelle le point
d'action chaque point d'action vaut
100000 euros et chaque compétence qu'il
souhaite utiliser vaut un certain nombre
de points d'action il connaissent le
tarif pour réaliser une action
spécifique ils doivent venir me voir et
me sudoyer ou venir voir Pauline qui se
reconnaît facilement avec son t-shirt je
suis une PNJ
[Musique]
piratage
sur moi le fait quand on est tout le
monde sur mon dos là ce qui m'a dit ça
parce que s'il m'a dit ça c'est qu'il
t'a trahi aussi
le petit sens son poste bien sûr
d'embauche bon le mec le patron il a pas
voulu prendre il m'a dit tout de suite
c'est un con
c'est vrai
désirée j'ai fait livrer un peu de
nourriture j'allais pas vous laisser
comme ça quand même si jamais vous avez
faim pour une fois c'est gratuit
bien sûr
c'est moi qui vous a recruté c'est pas
ce qui m'a dit précisément qui vous a
dit ça oui bien sûr que c'est moi un
système je vais j'apprécie beaucoup la
façon dont vous travaillez sachez le
c'est gentil
bien sûr bien sûr mais par contre dans
une famille des fois est-ce que vous
voulez oui c'est vrai que vous êtes là
un peu trop
je veux tout savoir
probablement en lien avec des actions
terroristes
voilà donc vous retrouvez peut-être pas
ça dans une pièce avec
elle c'est dommage qu'un autre ce soir
je trouve que vous êtes prêt sympathique
je connais un Japonais un client à moi
San ce monsieur
que je prends pour bronzer pour
recharger mes batteries tout à l'heure
dans mon bureau vous voulez vous dire ce
que j'étais en train de faire j'étais en
train de travailler sur un dossier
regardez il s'agit des accords de
YouTube ce serait une sorte de
Confédération Nationale des travailleurs
chrétiens aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
comment aider concrètement c'est
vidéaste alors moi j'ai pris
l'initiative de créer un accord qui nous
permettrait un petit peu plus
concrètement de régir un peu mieux les
relations entre YouTube et les employés
ça prend deux minutes vous signez juste
c'est une formalité et ça nous permettra
à tous de vivre dans un monde meilleur
c'est ce que vous voulez non vivre dans
un monde meilleur oui oui bien sûr je
vais le lire déjà je vais le lire est-ce
que vous pouvez me le rendre signer dans
ce cas d'ici 5 minutes oui je vous
laisse un stylo aussi à tout à l'heure
dans ce
la délégué du personnel m'a donné ça
pour prendre signe c'est hors de
question trouver un prétexte bidon je me
permets de le lire avant ok si je vous
dis que vous avez la preuve que les
démons ou les extraterrestres on
secrètement on va la planète votre père
et votre mère sont passés du côté des
aliens comment vous réagissez
est-ce que ça vaut le coup est-ce que
c'est rentable
[Musique]
il faut qu'on va quand même passer la
nuit avant pardon
il y a pas de prendre un petit peu de
votre temps oui c'est très bien merci
beaucoup
on en discute après
vous m'aviez demandé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous découvrez que votre patron a des
pratiques sexuelles étrange il fréquente
les clubs sadomaso qu'en pensez-vous
alors ça pour ceux qui aiment il y en a
ah ok alors non je suis contre aussi non
non vous allez m'aider
est-ce que vous voyez les hommes qui
sont là-bas le monsieur avec le costume
blanc monsieur fabette
vous allez essayer de les convaincre
pour moi de signer ceci c'est un accord
que j'ai moi-même écrit qui permettra de
d'un petit peu mieux régulariser les
relations entre les vidéastes et les
grands PDG grands patrons qui peuvent
pas à ça moi c'est l'argent
vous savez très bien ce que vous avez
fait vous savez très bien quand vous
l'avez fait donc quelles conditions vous
l'avez faites mais après c'est vous qui
allez vous retrouver dans une position
assez délicate et puis on gagne un petit
peu moins d'argent quand même quand on a
un sextape qui se retrouve littéralement
diffusée absolument partout vous savez
kim Kardashian a Bosé grâce à sa sextape
bah écoutez je vous laisse faire le test
il est temps de vous dire quelque chose
que cash Adrien sens que vous ne savez
pas encore Lucie appartement la
représentante syndicale de YouTube en
compagnie de ses camarades des cercles
chrétiens combattants pour la liberté de
contenu récemment organisé une descente
musclée au no limites le No Limit c'est
un club très fermé spécialisé dans les
plaisirs illicites pour Adrien aime se
rendre discrètement de temps en temps
pour je cite décompresser elle l'a
surpris dans une des chambres
capitonnées en tenue
sadomasochiste en train de fouetter
d'autres personnes Lucie c'est à leur
auto proclamé être le bras armé de Dieu
et elle lui a littéralement administré
le fouet pour pénitence de sa décadence
bourgeoise et pour avoir un moyen de
pression contre lui elle était allée
jusqu'à prendre la scène en photo ou
possède la pellicule qui pourrait ruiner
la réputation d'Adrien centre d'ailleurs
que faisait Adrien ce soir là au moment
du meurtre il était dans le bureau de
juste un risque il a porté la grille
confidentielle des vidéos privées cloudé
par les plus grosses scènes de la
plateforme parce qu'ils jettent un œil
avant Justin devait lui remettre comme
d'habitude une forte somme d'argent
liquide mais il a fait état d'un
contretemps financier pour différer le
paiement une fois qu'Adrien lui avait
remis la grille évidemment le ton est
rapidement monté entre Adrien sens et
juste un risque parce que c'est la
deuxième fois que Justin lui fait le
coup et Adrien commence à sentir un peu
le coup fourré alors Adrien menacé si
juste un ne paye pas ce soir ce qu'il
doit 5 points d'action soit 500000 euros
alors Adrien fera tout pour l'enfoncer
quels sont ses objectifs Adrien sens et
bien ils sont d'abord de se venger de
wooddeo pourquoi car la grande passion
d'Adrien vous le savez c'est le foot il
y a 30 soleil il a racheté le Vierzon
Atlantique et sous son impulsion et
grâce à son immense fortune il est
parvenu à faire de ce petit club de
province une équipe d'envergure
nationale après deux années deux fois
l'ascension la dernière saison a été une
catastrophe le club a fait défaite sur
des fêtes malgré les nombreux joueurs
internationaux que Adrien sens rémunéré
grassement alors plutôt que de perdre la
face il s'est résolu à tricher beaucoup
de clubs ont grand besoin d'argent frais
et de son côté il avait besoin de gagner
des matchs donc ils étaient faits pour
s'entendre le début de saison a donc vu
le retour du Vierzon Atlantique dans le
peloton de première des clubs de
division 1 seul nombreux tableau
l'humiliant défaites par 6-0 en Coupe
d'Europe contre l'Olympique de
Montélimar il y a trois semaines le club
de wildeo Adrien est d'autant plus
furieux qu'il l'avait quand même versé 6
millions d'euros son président wildeo
pour que son club perde il devrait
porter plainte difficile dans ce genre
d'affaires puisque tout est parfaitement
illégal mais la vengeance est un plat
qui se mange froid et Adrien trouvera
sûrement un moyen de renvoyer ça sa
politesse à vous dire il a aussi comme
objectif personnel de trouver de
l'argent partout les moyens c'est son
but pour ce soir les fortes sommes
versées au club de foot en mission la
paille il ne supporterait pas la honte
de la faillite mais si vous venez-vous
juste un risque lui doit 500000 euros
enfin dernier objectif il doit récupérer
absolument la pellicule avec la photo
compromettante que tu tiens Lucie
appartement ah oui un dernier détail
sera Adrien il doit pas sa réussite
sociale qu'elle ses propres aptitudes
professionnelles les traditions cultes
sont encore vivaces dans sa famille et
sa grand-mère était ce qui convient
d'appeler une sorcière une vraie de
vraie elle lui a légué certaines de ses
connaissances il n'a jamais hésité à se
servir d'une poupée vaudou lorsque le
besoin sans faisait sentir par exemple
ça ça me met dans l'embarras quand même
ça ça ne m'arrange pas du tout bon on va
tourner ça à notre avantage
quand vous étiez petit vous avez trouvé
une tortue dans le jardin
il fait chaud elle va mourir pourquoi
vous avez fait ça
[Musique]
comment je vais me démerder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un petit coup de jus
je ne sais pas exactement combien vous
m'en donnez 5 actions
500000 euros moi je vous dis quelque
chose je suis actuellement sur une piste
avec Madame appartement très peu de
temps je vais avoir une interaction avec
elle et je peux lui demander cette
statue je vous la récupère sans qu'elle
le sache mais pour trois actions non
oubliez oublier cette conversation vous
voulez des infos croustillantes bien sûr
vous pouvez me dire c'est qui le
meurtrier
je peux vous donner des informations
très compromettantes sur des gens que
vous connaissez bien ou que vous croyez
connaître je connais tout le monde les
connaissez pas au point que vous pensez
les connaître car vous ne les connaissez
pas oui j'allais me répéter la même
phrase
pour deux enfants deux enfants oh merci
si tu veux pour 5 ans tu m'en donnes 10
on a que des billets
ça va être compliqué cette histoire de
signature il va falloir aussi me donner
quelque chose bah c'est très simple je
vous donne le prix de la tranquillité la
pellicule c'est sous quel format
vous me donnez la pellicule je vous
donne le papier signé par tout le monde
je vais
là vous l'avez déjà comme vous avez fait
comment
on ne peut pas vous acheter
rien ne vous intéresse
[Musique]
vous êtes
masses années et vous êtes verrine love
de votre femme de votre mari de je ne
sais pas en tout cas si vous avez poussé
un cactus en sorte que vous rentrez chez
vous plutôt que prévu vous trouvez cette
personne au lit dans les bras de votre
meilleur ami que faites-vous de mon
meilleur ami
que faites-vous vous les trouvez au lit
ensemble
on discute
de la personne par exemple très mature
combien
[Musique]
juste un petit contrôle
une info gratos entre nous avec
l'information que je vous donne vous
pouvez presque aller voir ce site là
OK
qu'il a l'air un peu stressé ce se
cherche juste un risque baguette quoi
souvenez-vous au moment du meurtre ce
soir il était dans son bureau en
compagnie d'Adrien sens qui lui
remettait la grille de vidéo qui allait
sortir sur la plateforme le ton est
monté lorsque justin lui a annoncé qu'il
n'avait pas lui remettre l'argent
aujourd'hui mais les problèmes de Justin
sont plus anciens que ça encore depuis
qu'il travaille par YouTube son
existence jusqu'à leur facile et doré
prend plutôt des allers de cauchemars
lentement il a glissé sur la pointe
savonneuse de l'illégalité du vice et se
sent incapable de faire une marche
arrière le premier pas vers ce qu'on
pourra appeler le côté obscur fut son
entrée au sein du cercle de jeu très
fermé donc je vous ai déjà parlé l'as de
pique club vous se réunissent tous les
gros bonnets de la pègre quelques
industriels richissimes c'est alphabet
qui l'a introduit là-bas les sommes qui
sont jouées sont souvent colossales il a
beaucoup beaucoup perdu un jour vous
allez vraiment pas juste un confier ses
angoisses à des dimensions vous
connaissez je vous l'ai présenté c'est
le directeur des network chez YouTube
Dali lui a proposé de l'aider à tricher
au poker grâce à un ingénieux système de
micro et caméra cachée en échange de la
particip financière de Justin dans sa
société de snuff movie vous vous
rappelez les films TDR Justin accepté sa
proposition mais il savait pas à ce
moment-là à quel point il allait le
regretter d'aller mention la récemment
soumis à un autre dieu Chantal il
voulait assassiner Julien fitcha et
filmer le meurtre pour le diffuser sur
Youtube en faisant croire que la carte
SD avait été envoyée ensuite par un le
mystérieux céréal killer vous connaissez
Dali tout pour les vues et la YouTube
monnaie si Justin refusait de tuer
Julien fit et de lui arracher le foie
pendant que Dali filmait la scène alors
d'allier raconterai toutes les
tricheries qu'il a fait au membres de
l'As de Pique impossible de refuser pour
Justin le soir d'une meurtre on montre à
quelques semaines d'alimentation soudain
grassement l'indivigule chargée de la
protection vos projets de Julien fitzat
à balle second puis le temps le Beretta
9 mm Agustin lui redonne de descendre le
vidéaste caméra à la main Dali a filmé
toute la scène l'horreur a atteint son
paroxysme lorsque Dali a obligé Justin à
découper le foie de la victime avec une
paire de ciseaux c'est vrai juste un
reste traumatisé à ce jour ce soir les
objectifs de Justin sont de ramasser de
l'argent par tous les moyens de faire
plonger d'alimentation qu'il a obligé à
commettre un meurtre et de se discuter
du meurtre de Julien fit en particulier
et des autres meurtres en général dont
celui de ce soir celui de vous rendre
chez vous et vous surprenez vos fils
votre fils en train de regarder une
vidéo pour adulte que
faites un peu en plus
que peut-être il pourra garder ça un
petit peu plus tard toujours dans le
tank la discussion
très très jolie score vous savez on
n'est pas poste auquel je suis
aujourd'hui sans la communication avec
ses employés je pense que je peux vous
donner une information
très honnêtement
fait
Interpol la recherche ah bon
[Musique]
connaissez pas pur hasard une
organisation qui s'appelle réelle seule
comme le Sunshine comme le soleil soleil
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui s'appellerait Joe bien
joué tôt peut-être bien joué
le seul c'est un homme un gourou
[Musique]
il a des relations avec ces plateformes
là très violente avec un homme que je
connaissais qui s'appelle bien joué
attention moi je pense que vous devez
poser des questions à comment il
s'appelle qui parle tout le temps oui je
m'entretien vous me tiendrez au courant
merci beaucoup merci à vous messieurs
Dali
je vous rende 500
[Musique]
à mon avis
un petit peu bizarre
[Musique]
pour cette histoire de
de trucs là le petit symbole chétif
chrétien c'est ça je ne sais pas
exactement
d'accord
alors
[Musique]
ça vaut bien trois actions
non seulement vous l'aurez pas mais en
plus elle saura que vous le voulez alors
là vous êtes double perdant
[Musique]
dans un coin du coup je suis persuadée
ici mais quel genre de démon qu'est-ce
que vous voulez dire par là un vrai
démon je pense qu'ici il y a quelqu'un
qui est possédé parce que vous savez
qu'il y a un vrai démon je sais qu'il y
a un vrai démon ici donc vous pouvez
dire que quelqu'un est possédé
actuellement oui et je pense que c'est
cette personne là qui est le meurtrier
vous pensez que les meurtres seraient dû
à une sorte de possession démoniaque oui
d'accord et je tente mais est-ce que
vous avez entendu parler cette
association de
de personnes qui
comment dire qui chassent les démons
avec des méthodes un peu j'en ai entendu
violentes
c'est ça ouais et est-ce que vous faites
partie de Doom pourquoi vous demandez ça
parce que je suis curieuse vous êtes en
train de me demander si je fais partie
de l'association qui chasse les démons
ça change je crois au démon et ça change
absolument rien au démon mais je vais
considérer cette réponse comme ah oui
écoutez je pense qu'on est dans le même
camp
je pense que on doit avoir des amis en
commun effectivement est-ce que pas oui
ou pas non vous pouvez me répondre
est-ce que vous faites partie de
l'ascension oui je fais partie de la
situation merci pour votre franchise
cette discussion pourrait sembler
étrange mais comme vous le savez sauf si
il fait bien partie du doom pourquoi
alors cette chère Lucie s'y intéresse
elle aussi et bien je vous parle d'elle
et franchement vous êtes pas prêt Lucie
est délégué syndicale c'est ok mais
c'est surtout un ange un vrai un vrai de
vrai avec les petites plumes et tout
dans le dos alors pas une autre
responsable de la hiérarchie angélique
juste un petit Séraphin envoyé en
mission sur terre dans le corps de Lucie
appartement pour assister les hommes et
les remettre dans le droit chemin cette
pauvre Lucie appartement la vraie avait
été victime d'un grave accident et les
médecins avaient annoncé sa mort
clinique parce que soudainement à la
reprise en fait c'était au moment où
l'ange prenais possession de son corps
et sa première phrase a été je suis en
mission pour le Seigneur elle a été
envoyé parce que les pompes du Paradis
ont remarqué une augmentation assez
importante du nombre de suicides parmi
les employés de chez YouTube le suicide
c'est un péché mortel et toutes les âmes
de suicidé sont promises à la damnation
éternelle son travail consiste désormais
à trouver l'origine de ses rapide afin
de remédier rapidement à ce problème
voilà donc trois ans maintenant quel
travail chez YouTube au service
assistance dès son arrivée chez YouTube
elle a monté la première organisation
syndicale de la boîte affiliale des
travailleurs chrétiens dont aller la
déléguer sur la plateforme elle milite
au sein de nombreux groupes de chrétiens
de gauche qui ont pris conscience de la
décadence de notre société qui veulent
agir pour préparer le grand soir il y a
15 jours elle a envoyé sous la signature
mystérieuse de l'ange Gabriel un petit
mail au Doom le groupe de jeunes gens
qui se battent contre les démons vous
souvenez elle sait comment éliminer un
démon il faut rester trois fois la
formule 6 6 kumakukuma opumakuma à voix
haute sans se tromper puis dire vadérer
trop plus le nom du démon en pointant un
crucifix dans la direction de la bête
alors que faisait Lucie notre ange le
soir du meurtre elle n'avait pas quitté
les bureaux de YouTube parce qu'elle
avait une réunion de sa cellule à
préparer et le voulait finir de rédiger
les accords de YouTube qu'elle appelle
ironiquement son pacte avec les démons
elle a passé toute la soirée dans son
bureau euros sans voir personne et elle
était très surprise lorsque je suis
arrivé pour lui annoncer la mort de chou
entier malheureusement elle n'a aucun
alibi puisqu'elle était seule au moment
du crime ses objectifs personnels de ce
soir sont d'obtenir de meilleures
conditions de vie pour les créateurs
afin de prévenir les nouveaux suicides à
la pour ça élaborer des nouveaux accords
de YouTube régissant les relations entre
les dirigeants et les vidéastes et elle
doit les faire absolument signer à
d'alimentation juste un risque et
alphabet elle peut aussi utiliser la
photo compromettante qu'elle a de Adrien
sens pour faire pression sur lui vous le
savez il sait qu'elle possède cette
photo et enfin comme tout le monde ici
elle doit se disculper du meurtre de
chou entier de ce soir pourquoi pas en
chargeant ses propres patrons
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé ceci dans le bureau de notre
cher PDG international de YouTube France
OK
et je n'ai absolument aucune idée
pourquoi est-ce qu'il aurait ça
n'a aucun sens on dirait qu'il recherche
quelqu'un je me suis pas donné la peine
parce que je pense que là concrètement
l'indice que ça nous donne ce que il
recherche quelqu'un ou en tout cas il a
des options sur l'identité de quelqu'un
bon c'est parti je vais faire les
fausses signatures
[Musique]
ok moi j'ai fouillé le bureau de juste
un risque ok qu'est-ce que vous avez
trouvé ben j'ai trouvé l'arme du crime
ouais
[Musique]
si on résume on a donc alphabet
son regard pour moi c'est pas un regard
très il a l'air hanté donc alphabet
suspect on a juste un risque qui est un
peu le potentiellement suspect puisqu'il
y avait l'art du crime dans son bureau
une oreillette une oreillette ok je
pense qu'il faut qu'on y retourne et
attention du coup à Madison
[Musique]
m'a demandé de fouiller le bureau de
d'alimentation je suis très embêté parce
que c'est pas très légal mais il assume
me convaincre qui me fait pas tarder à
aller l'emmener voir ça c'est ici
regardez c'est là
voilà le bureau je vous laisse 30
secondes pour trouver quelque chose
parce que après tout le monde tout le
monde va se poser des questions
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons pas vous faire voir ces
images mais le fichier indique qu'il
vient d'être ouvert il y a quelques
heures à peine entre deux gicles
immondes de sang on comprend ça peine
qu'il s'agit du film de l'assassinat de
Max Birk il s'agit des rushs et
plusieurs scènes apparaissent sous
différents angles la carte SD porte la
mention TD
qu'est-ce que c'est que
TRD
SD dans votre bureau on va dire
ça au bureau pour les diffuser après
c'est mon devoir d'information parce que
vous vous savez quoi sur TDR peut-être
qu'on peut partager des informations
essayez de trouver qui les envoyer je
vais essayer de
me renseigner là-dessus
un échange de une information
contre mon ami avec le casque
elle s'appelle Sophie
ça fonctionne il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord
[Musique]
beaucoup d'enfants
est-ce que vous souhaitez regarder
celle de chantier celle de des
empreintes des autres meurtres
vous savez je vais être sympa avec vous
donner accès quelques secondes à un
document et je fermerai les yeux
là-dessus
je reviens
je commence
pour me faire confiance
tout le monde me demande où vous êtes
passé ça a commencé à être louche je
vais pas pouvoir recouvrir plus de temps
écoutez de mon avis si vous voulez mon
avis de spécialistes
je trouve ça ressemble un peu à celle-ci
ok évidemment on ne s'est pas vu vous
n'êtes pas venu
est-ce que vous voyez le club un peu
libertin où il y a des prostituées des
gens de petites mœurs qui se débouchent
et dans lequel une personne a été tuée
il se peut que notre cher ami un peu
du coup j'ai l'information qui me
manquait je vous remercie beaucoup
Monsieur
[Musique]
dans ton dos et j'ai cru que c'était toi
j'ai pas mal de personnes moi j'ai pas
de temps à perdre avec ça
[Musique]
mon cher ami barbu
je le range vous voulez vraiment de
sécurité demain matin je diffuse les
photos de vous en train de vous faire
frapper les fesses donc là concrètement
vous voulez qu'on aille dans un contenu
discret vous avez la possibilité de tout
changer sur Youtube vous savez papier
c'est de l'or vous voulez combien
d'actions
petite action ça fait toujours plaisir
hop les bons comptes font les bons amis
voilà et ça reste entre nous hein
[Musique]
bon bah j'ai pris une petite action des
fausses signatures tout est super tout
est top c'est une question par hasard à
moi
une pizza
il met tout le monde contre vous là
[Musique]
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter un tout
petit peu avec notre ami risque qui m'a
qui a voulu
me vendre des informations à ton sujet
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure je donne un
faux sourire
qui a été relevé
quand on parle de qualité
[Applaudissements]
une information contre une que j'avais
pas il m'a dit à ta copine mais si toi
Benjamin il faut absolument que je le
remercie ah oui pourquoi parce que si je
trouve le démon il faut que vous
puissiez
ok
donc mission récupérer le crucifix
je sais pas du coup je vais il faut que
je vois ok je te propose je te propose
qu'on essaie un petit peu de
force
il cherche que ça il a voulu racheter le
crucifix je pense qu'on peut essayer de
l'avoir plus fine
si tu veux pas dépenser ton argent je
vais interroger will essaie de retrouver
ton crucifix et on fait le point après
d'accord mon cher ami à pantalon à
carreaux comment allez-vous est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on se pose deux secondes
comme je vous l'ai déjà dit les joueurs
possèdent des actions spéciales Lucie
contre 200000 euros de points d'action
peut utiliser son pouvoir pour connaître
le plus grand péché d'une personne pour
y parvenir il faut d'abord que son
interlocuteur accepte de lui ouvrir son
coeur il suffit qu'elle discute avec
quelqu'un et que le mot oui soit
prononcé n'importe où dans la réponse
pour que son pouvoir fonctionne
[Applaudissements]
j'adore Jésus je l'aime j'aime la
religion j'aime tout et j'aime les gens
qui aiment Jésus j'aime les gens je
pense
il me semble que vous avez quelque chose
qui m'appartient quelle chose une petite
chose en bois le crucifix
est-ce que vous n'avez jamais de moment
un peu plus difficile de des moments de
tête où vous avez besoin de
d'extérioriser aussi des émotions qui
sont présentes depuis peut-être
longtemps et vous avez des personnes à
qui vous confier dans ces mots là une
famille des proches
je suis assez seul c'est vrai que je
parle pas beaucoup de certains de mes
côtés un peu plus qui sont un peu plus
au fond de moi mais le bouquin
ou pas
[Musique]
moi je suis au top tout le temps le truc
c'est ça c'est que je ne sais pas ce que
c'est un dépression par exemple pour moi
la dépression n'existe pas la dépression
c'est un shot de whisky la dépression et
les parties comme je dis
mais du coup vous êtes enfin je veux
dire on est d'accord que
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué il
fait plus chaud vous avez chaud un petit
peu un petit peu il fait de plus en plus
chaud parce que Madame MC Perlen a
décidé de monter tous les chauffages
je ne l'empêche pas de le faire mais je
sais pas pourquoi elle a voulu faire ça
mais voilà j'ai accepté la clim et
maintenant c'est Madame McLaren qui
apparemment c'est les techniques à
l'américaine font monter le chauffage de
monter le chauffage
on prend pas c'est le temps de parler
toutes ces choses là est-ce que vous
voudriez vous comment dire qu'on discute
avec grand plaisir
vous êtes beaux au revoir
le coup ça fonctionne à chaque fois
et c'est un oui qui a enfin été prononcé
apparemment c'était galère et c'est à ce
moment précis que Lucie appartenant a pu
comprendre que le plus grand péché de 8
vidéos c'est le meurtre oui leo est donc
un assassin vous avez maintenant un gros
coup d'avant sur les joueurs pour suivre
la partie parlons un peu plus de wildeo
c'est donc un meurtrier pour être exact
les images ne sont pas très claires dans
sa tête mais ils se souvient d'avoir
assassiné au moins quatre des cinq
personnes magif et y maxburg matfor
échoue entier ce soir pour Julien
fitschatz il n'en a aucun souvenir
évidemment puisque vous le savez
maintenant c'est juste un risque qui a
assassiné Julien fitchade sur les ordres
et la pression de d'alimentation et
pourtant même pour ça
wildeo c'est tellement flou qu'il ne
peut juré de rien comment il peut être
le mystérieux céréales killer tueur de
vidéastes sans en avoir la certitude
absolue tout simplement parce que oui
est gravement malade depuis longtemps et
qui lui arrive fréquemment de faire des
choses qui l'oublient ensuite c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé pour les
quatre assassinats il a la certitude
d'être le coupable mais il l'ignore
réellement pourquoi il les a tué et les
circonstances des meurtres sont
extrêmement nébuleuses dans son esprit
il est atteint d'une schizophrénie
mythomanie qui a tendance sadique qui
lui a d'ailleurs valu de connaître
pendant plusieurs années l'hôpital
psychiatrique et il a mis fin en
traitement depuis quelques années enfin
ça c'est très important et très
intéressant depuis peu c'est le second
actionnaire de YouTube justement
récemment les actions de YouTube ont
soudainement chuté d'un seul coup après
une déclaration d'alphabète qui
annonçait de très mauvais résultats pour
cette année d'alimentation à leur
prévenir will qui s'agissait d'un coup
monté par alphabet qui comptait racheter
lui-même les titres après quelques jours
de baisse oui il l'a donc grillé au
poteau alphabet a pas dû tellement
apprécié mais il a rien pu faire contre
ça mais alors que faisait exactement
wildeo ce soir vers 20h il a eu un coup
de téléphone de l'alphabet qui lui a
demandé de venir pour des questions de
contrat
des affaires urgentes il est arrivé vers
21h il est monté dans son bureau où il a
appelé le choix entier en lui demandant
de le rejoindre ensuite il est allé au
bureau de alphabet il a regardé les
contrats ils ont discuté ensemble
ensuite alphabet lui a dit qu'il était
un petit peu fatigué au bout de trois
quart d'heure alphabet a raccompagné
Willis jusqu'à son bureau et d'ici will
à étudier les contrats qu'il avait du
coup en main et puis très rapidement
muet pas une sorte de force étrange oui
il s'est précipité vers le parking pour
intercepter chaud entier au moment où il
rentrait dans l'ascenseur qui mène aux
étages avant que je sois entier le temps
de dire un mot où il lui a tiré une
balle dans la tête puis lui a sectionné
le foie avec un couteau et enfin oui il
a regagné son bureau il s'est lavé les
mains en hâte et c'est là que moi je
l'ai trouvé en train de se laver les
mains pour lui annoncer la mort de chou
entier quels sont ses objectifs
personnels pour ce soir tout d'abord se
disculper des meurtres en chargeant
alphabet dans le but de prendre sa place
comme ça c'est réglé il veut aussi
comprendre ce qui lui arrive et enfin
que tout il veut être aimé et apprécié
de tout le monde est-ce que vous
connaissez
à quel prix un seul homme qui
s'appellerait Sun seul
idée de qu'il s'agit non vous avez lu un
article
d'accord dites-moi rien du tout vous
n'avez aucune information ça ne vous
parle pas
merci monsieur
songe est en train de vriller sur le
haut
très bien
je pense que je vais vous demander
d'accéder au fichiers de la police
monsieur
il m'a dit que c'est
Adrien sens qui a mangé
contre une information ou de l'argent
peut-être ok l'avantage c'est que je
peux faire pression sur Adrien
[Musique]
vous avez pris quoi dans le sac
si elle a un crucifix
de particularité c'est vraiment de
j'arrive très facilement à voir quels
sont les grands péchés des gens
et disons que je sais que notre cher ami
huile est un meurtrier d'accord alors
est-ce que il a commis ce crime en
particulier ou est-ce qu'il est en lien
avec les autres crimes notamment celui
du de là où j'ai trouvé l'autre en train
de se faire fouetter les fesses je n'ai
aucune idée je sais qu'il est meurtrier
mais je ne sais pas qui il a tué en
revanche ça commence à faire beaucoup de
faisceaux d'indice on sait qu'il est
meurtriers et il y avait quoi d'autre à
l'empreinte l'empreinte sur l'arbre
c'est la scène mais je trouve ça trop
gros écoute moi j'ai un outil qui me
permet de faire une vérification ok je
peux voir s'il est possédé moi je pense
pas que ce soit pressé beaucoup tu
penses que c'est un peu stupide mais il
est pas possédé tu vois je pense que
alphabète depuis le début je l'ai jamais
senti ce gars mais vraiment depuis que
j'ai commencé à travailler à Youtube
c'est très simple il me fait froid dans
le dos est-ce que tu as vu les cernes
qu'il a les espèces de bénabarente etc
donc toi tu penses que c'est lui qui est
possédé ok essaie de partir en
vérification auprès de Will quand on
vérifier que il est pas possédé ou alors
auprès de alphabet de mon côté je vais
aller essayer de te récupérer ton
crucifié ok donc moi je check oui
merci beaucoup
merci
on arrive assez rapidement au milieu de
l'enquête je sais pas si les 6p se
rendent compte mais
je sais pas si tout le monde avance bien
comme il faut quand même et surtout
pour Lucie vous êtes au courant
la secte
je m'en sors toujours bien
j'ai pas d'infos donc je vous laisse une
intuition
j'ai vu votre nom tout à l'heure ma main
droite
qu'est-ce qu'elle a maman
elle avait du sang
pourquoi c'est vrai
un petit peu de sang sur votre poignet
sur le poignet
regardez ça c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
va manger un petit burger
allez hop
ce soir
ça me fait 900 000 ouais c'est pas mal
ouais faudrait une dernière petite
action pour faire un petit million
[Musique]
si j'arrive à vendre ça
pour faire un petit million 5 pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez augmenté
[Musique]
monsieur
je pense que j'ai trouvé top
belle soirée nous ça vous pose problème
en plus
vous voulez faire quoi vous voulez faire
quoi par exemple
sans exception
en fait là vous êtes en train de me
faire
il y a une signature de trop
comment se fait-il qu'il y a quatre
signatures alors que la dernière
signature essenti être la mienne et je
vous en avais seulement demandé de
pouvoir ça ça doit être parce que la
double et sa signature est-ce que vous
avez vraiment fait signer les bonnes
personnes
[Musique]
je vais faire un tour j'arrive
je sais pas de quoi il parle qui c'est
qui
je vais le défoncer bon moi je vais
faire un tour
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez votre petite corde
vous savez où on a tous mis les
empreintes
d'identité si c'est ça que vous me
demandez j'ai un doute sur votre nom
non vous ne voulez pas je vous montre ma
carte d'identité si vous voulez
faire très important d'avoir confiance
les uns dans les autres dans les autres
je pense que si vous ne mangez pas c'est
que vous n'avez pas confiance monsieur
[Musique]
ces activités du doom Sophie utilisent
sont détecteur de démons à
antiprotoniques c'est un détecteur qui
se présente sous la forme d'un
sèche-cheveux relie une calculatrice
mais c'est bien détecteur à démon voilà
quand Sophie pointe son détecteur en
direction d'une personne elle doit être
assez proche de la personne elle obtient
résultat elle a assez d'énergie pour se
servir de l'appareil seulement deux fois
ce soir au moment où Sophie le pointe
sur wildeo elle découvre qu'il n'est pas
un démon
elle sait qu'elle se fait rouler la
question c'est comment le piège lui et
pourquoi il a fait ça moi être impliqué
à des trucs de secte ça m'intéresse pas
devant de sexe vous avez vu son document
les trucs du Seigneur du machin merci
particulier nous dirons
[Musique]
à l'intérieur je pense que j'ai un doigt
de regard sur votre carte d'identité
vous inquiétez pas c'est bizarre quand
même
moi aussi mais là je dois vous avouer
que je pense qu'on va subtiliser ma
carte
vous avez trouvé des infos intéressantes
intéressantes
en ce qui me concerne
très bien
[Musique]
ces actions sont réalisées vous avez
besoin que je vous explique quand un
joueur veut utiliser une compétence il
vient me voir moi au Pauline donc si un
joueur qui a la compétence de pickpocket
veut voler dans les poches de quelqu'un
il vient d'abord me voir il me soudoit
pour réaliser son action et il me dit
qu'elle poche précisément il veut
fouiller il ne peut fouiller qu'une
seule poche à la fois et c'est Pauline
moi qui allons récupérer ce qu'il y a
dans la poche de la personne qui n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'accepter tout ça
évidemment pour préserver l'anonymat de
la personne qui a pratiqué le Big
pocketisme tous les joueurs savaient ça
j'ai beaucoup insisté dessus ce qui
explique par exemple la tendance de
juste un risque à dispatcher tout son
argent dans plusieurs poches l'erreur
d'Adrien sens a été de tout conserver au
même endroit monsieur fabette je vous
laisse quelques minutes
et après je vous ramène sinon ça va être
suspect
vous l'avez pas dit mais où l'idéo adore
faire des procès à tout le monde et
alphabet ne vient de tomber sur le net
de l'avocat de Windeo maître bobard
montrant que Will voulais assigner les
deux premières victimes en justice pour
diffamation l'avocat de Will explique
que le dossier qu'il a monté contre chou
entier et trop mince pour l'attaque
linguistique et bien sûr je suis
spécialiste dans le sérieux
ils sont plusieurs monsieur
c'est un très bon moment merci beaucoup
alors oui mention qu'est-ce qui se passe
un peu fatigué
vous avez des informations sur une secte
[Musique]
de l'argent je sais des trucs
très bonne affaire monsieur
vous savez faire vous alors je sais que
les deux personnes les plus impliquées
dans le Sun sont madame MCF Line et
Monsieur risque
elle est à la recherche justement d'un
des leaders du Sun qui seraient ici
selon elle monsieur risque et oui
monsieur risque nous donne une autre
version que Madame mcfarine n'est pas
agent du FBI ni de la CIA mais qu'elle
travaille pour le Sun quoi qu'il en soit
chacun sa cuisine il y en a forcément un
des deux impliqué dans le Sun maintenant
reste à savoir quelle version est la
vraie quelle version est la France selon
vous je crois madame max je pense
qu'elle est vraiment agent et qu'elle
est vue dû régler les comptes de
Monsieur risk je l'ai senti
très très très très très très en
banqueroute vous savez que ces histoires
de meurtre elle est pour objectif aussi
de baisser les actions YouTube sauf que
Monsieur déo a pris l'avantage
à acheter des actions avant ce qui avait
prévu monsieur risque et Monsieur
fabette ils se sont faits doubler
monsieur
venez et oui monsieur mention j'ai
confiance en vous mais je crois qu'on
est les seuls à être
innocence
je vais chercher de l'argent monsieur
fabette
récupérer énormément mais ce que je peux
vous demander de prendre juste 100000
juste pour le garder
juste pour le conserver sur vous en
attendant je récupère le reste ah bon ok
d'autre part vous aviez beaucoup
d'argent sur vous vous l'avez toujours
mais non on l'a volé hier
l'information je ne sais pas pourquoi il
m'a donné cette information je ne dis
pas que c'est lui je dis juste qu'il est
venu me donner l'information peut-être
qu'il a donné l'information à quelqu'un
[Musique]
pour prendre un médicament c'est ça
exactement je dois prendre mon
médicament mettez-vous dans ce bureau
mon portefeuille
[Musique]
c'est risqué
quand est-ce que vous allez me rendre
mon portefeuille
[Musique]
je suis allé dans ton bureau
j'ai pris une photo je l'ai trouvé dans
son bureau
je sais pas mon appareil photo
tout à l'heure
je viens de trouver l'arme du crime dans
le bureau de Monsieur Dao
[Musique]
je viens de trouver cette arme
maintenant dans le bureau de Monsieur
[Musique]
dans son bureau je reviens juste bougez
pas on va l'envoyer à la scientifique
l'huile que vous l'avez trouvé dans le
bureau de Monsieur déo exactement
[Musique]
ça vous est pas venu à l'esprit de le
prendre comme ça plutôt que mettre vos
grosses peluches dessus
je ne crois personne je l'envoie la
scientifique et on verra ça
malheureusement que demain vous êtes
encore plus suspect tous les deux en
tout cas c'était dans son bureau c'est
sous pression des hautes et sous
pression tu vas craquer je te le dis tu
vas craquer tu vas prendre le pouce
c'est ça tu vas prendre le poulpe
je vais vous défoncer
je pense que c'est passé par juste un
risque avant de vous attirer dans vos
mains lui il avait besoin d'argent
et du coup vous avez revendu le crucifix
combien beaucoup
il m'a fait une avance
[Musique]
crucifié ou papier
je sais sur quel corps était cadeau
les empreintes relevées sur la scène du
crime qui a eu lieu ici même ce soir
sont celles de la personne qui
s'approche ce sont celles de
Willows ce ne sont pas les mêmes
mesdames et messieurs je pense qu'il est
temps de parler un peu plus de alphabet
vous avez peut-être des soupçons sur lui
son nom revient dans quasiment toutes
les enquêtes alternatives dans toutes
les embrouilles alors je vais vous
donner tous les secrets qui vont vous
permettre d'apprécier encore plus la
suite de l'enquête de cette vidéo on va
commencer par l'essentiel c'est
l'assassin
à un meurtre près celui de Julien
fitchaatz qui a été tué par jarisk sous
les ordres de dalination alphabet c'est
un démon c'est le démon le corrupteur
des hommes le propagateur du vice du
désespoir et de la destruction c'est lui
en tant que démon ça fait bien longtemps
qu'il a compris que la modernité
actuelle lui donnait plein de nouveaux
moyens très efficaces pour accomplir son
œuvre maléfique alors il y a quelques
années il a racheté une plateforme
prometteuse youtube il y a quelques
temps il est apparu successivement à
quatre jeunes vidéastes qui vraiment
ambitionné des grandes choses sur le
plateforme Maggie et y maxbird matfor
est chaud entier leur première vidéo et
les emplois qui qui
occupaient ne répondaient vraiment pas
leur désirs de gloire d'argent et de
pouvoir ils allaient pas bien les quatre
la frustration l'amertume les avait à
culot désespoir et quand le démon s'est
révélé à eux sous sa forme démoniaque il
s'apprêtait à commettre le graphe péché
du suicide alors le démon alphabète leur
a proposé un marché leur offrir tout ce
qu'il voulait les vues l'argent la
gloire le pouvoir mais passer un délai
il devrait se suicider pour de bon leurs
âmes appart dès lors alphabet aucun des
quatre n'a hésité ils ont tous dit Oui
puis le démon les a plongés dans un
profond commun chacun de ces quatre
vidéastes ont ensuite été retrouvés dans
des circonstances évoquants sans aucun
doute une tentative de suicide les
quatre n'en gardés de la visite du démon
qu'un souvenir imprécis un cauchemar
qu'ils ont essayé d'oublier et aucun
d'entre eux ne s'inquiéta du virage
brutal que pris alors leur destin nombre
d'abonnés partenariat en or vu
incroyable ça a été très facile à partir
de là pour eux mais aucun ne se
doutèrent jamais que le grand patron de
YouTube alphabet n'était autre que lui
le mystérieux visiteur d'un soir le
démon une fois le délai écoulé de leur
contrat démoniaque le démon est revenu
pour exiger son dû avec les fiches
psychologiques qu'il avait fait établir
sous tous les vidéastes de YouTube ils
connaissaient très bien leur point
faible ce n'était pas compliqué pour lui
de les forcer de les contraintes à
mettre fin à leurs jours cette condition
est d'ailleurs nécessaire pour que leur
âme lui appartienne définitivement le
fait de pousser les gens au suicide
c'est d'ailleurs inhérent à sa nature
des démons pour le premier meurtre celui
de fy
faire fu vite réglé quelques menaces en
suffit pour qu'elle mette fin un séjour
ah et pourquoi l'ablation du foie bossez
le c'est le petit détail sanglant qu'il
a imaginé pour égarer la police et la
presse sur la piste d'un hypothétique
serial killer psychopathe pour le
deuxième meurtre celui de Max Birk
l'histoire est plus intéressante ce
dernier avait décidé de faire la fête au
club no limites le club privé dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de plaisir
illicite et quand petit matin les
convives étaient encore sous l'effet des
drogues il est apparu à maxber pour
réclamer son vu en lui provoquant
d'horrible vision donc ça a été très
facile de pousser au suicide pour le
troisième meurtre là vous le savez vous
c'est différent pendant ce temps sur
Youtube les assassinats de Maggie fait
y&m max bird on fait naître une vocation
Julien fitchatz l'autre vidéaste a été
assassiné abattu d'une balle dans la
tête et son foie prélevé mais vous savez
qui c'est et vous savez aux ordres de
qui était cette personne ce que vous
savez pas encore c'est que la presse et
la police se posent des questions car de
nombreux détails qui n'ont pas été
révélés au public nous font penser à
nous autres policiers que ce meurtre est
différent des autres tout d'abord si
l'armée bien toujours
pour le principe d'une balle dans le dos
et il a pris son foie mais pour le coup
son âme lui a échappé puisqu'elle a
refusé de suicider donc à la rompu le
contrat qui le liait à lui mais le démon
a trois visages chez les humains
alphabètes évidemment mais aussi celui
du Grand Sun le gourou absolu de la
secte Sun qui arrondit ses fins de moi
avec son son réseau d'être humain et
drogue ainsi que l'identité de Jean-Paul
bien joué Joe l'agent secret
officiellement au service de la DGSE
mais toujours prêt à vendre une
information confidentielle au plus
offrant surtout si ça peut mettre la
pagaille c'est classique mais ça marche
bien mais alors attention il a beau être
un démon extraordinairement puissant
vous le savez il n'est pas un vulnérable
son point faible c'est son nom
démoniaque il suffit que quelqu'un
prenne un crucifix dans sa direction en
disant sisi Kuma coucou maokumakuma à
voix haute et sans se tromper puis dire
va derretro mephistophéless et son
esprit infernal est immédiatement envoyé
dans les lames pour l'éternité alors
vous me direz il suffit que jamais
personne découvre son nom mais c'est pas
si simple il y a une loi divine qui date
du déluge qui impose à tous les démons
de laisser aux hommes un moyen de
découvrir son nom et le rien qu'à
imaginer mes pistes aux félès pour
dissimuler son nom et certes assez tordu
mais la loi divine n'interdit pas aux
démons des tordu les indices sont dans
l'organigramme de ces sociétés qui est
visible sur le mur de toutes les pièces
alors comment il a fait pour le meurtre
de ce soir de chou entier pourquoi will
dhéo est persuadé d'être le tueur
pourquoi il utilise pas ses pouvoirs de
démon ce soir quels sont ses objectifs
personnels il reste quand même beaucoup
de questions sans réponse auquel je vous
répondrai plus tard vous avez pas de
piste vous avez pas d'infos vous avez
vous savez que j'ai trouvé quand même le
Beretta dans le bureau
c'est pas vrai la première fois depuis
30 ans en fait
[Musique]
alors du coup l'info ça serait bien une
info contre le crucifix c'est pas de
l'argent mais ça va j'ai plus de sous je
suis assez con m'a volé mon si vous
retrouvez par contre mon portefeuille je
vous donne le coup si je vous donne tout
j'ai une question comment est-ce que
vous allez convaincre les grands patrons
de signer mon accord parce que moi je
suis d'accord votre portefeuille je peux
aller rechercher par contre
et dans nos mutuellement sens
ations
mesdames et messieurs pour information
dans 15 minutes les fourgons seront là
pour vous transférer au commissariat
un petit peu tout le monde
est-ce que la meurtre
dont je connais l'origine ne serait pas
directement aux autres
on revient à mon histoire de contrat
comment est-ce que vous comptez le faire
signer parce que moi il faut répondre à
ma question
je vous explique si on sait si parmi ces
gens là il y a les traces sur le Beretta
je vais pouvoir les faire signer en les
menaçant
sinon je peux pas j'en ai marre d'accord
j'en ai marre d'accord
ce que je me flingue c'est ça
écartez-vous tout va bien
se passer vous calmez-vous calmez-vous
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y a rien qui va là et tout le monde
m'accuse que c'est j'ai moi je vais en
finir vous allez vous avez l'air au bout
du rouleau monsieur risque vous avez
l'air au bout du rouleau ça vous fait
rire ça va très bien se passer allez
calmez-vous maintenant
calmez-vous qu'est-ce qui se passe
vous êtes au bout du rouleau ça va pas
on va on va appeler un psychologue on va
appeler un psychologue qui viendra vous
voir tout à l'heure
j'en peux plus il y a trop de choses à
gérer c'est d'accord moi je suis rien on
est obligé de toute façon d'avancer les
pions moi je m'engage à essayer de
signer ça mais vous vous êtes la seule à
pouvoir faire démarrer cette enquête OK
mais par contre si c'est lui qui le
portefeuille
on a vraiment de quoi faire chanter et
moi j'ai doublement de colle
on peut pas enlever le catéchisme
bon je vais essayer je reviens vers vous
OK
sur la tentative de suicide
pour moi faut pas sombrer comme ça
qu'il est venu comme ça il a vu le foot
aucune idée comme je vous l'ai dit
Justin c'est un peu l'âme d’année de
fabette fabette lui remet régulièrement
de l'argent liquide qui vient de se
rémunération en tant que bien joué le
Joe et fabette l'a également introduit
au club de poker très privé l'as de
pique là-bas les mises à peine souvent
des sommes astronomiques et fabett a
plusieurs fois de nez des petits coups
de pouce à juste un risque pour épurer
ses dettes en tout cas au début
aujourd'hui Justin doit 500.000 euros 5
points d'action alpha bet qui compte pas
la chaîne de morceaux de jeux dettes
d'honneur et c'est bien le fait que
Justin soit souvent en présence du démon
qui le détruit psychologiquement un peu
plus à chaque minute passer en sa
présence
je crois que nous allons devoir annuler
notre date
il se trouve que j'ai appris des choses
assez compromettantes à votre sujet
ce soir pour récupérer toutes ces
actions qui va être inculpé monsieur déo
pourquoi pour l'arme et pour d'autres
trucs
pour commencer pour le moment moi je
propose un échange d'accord
je dis pas à tout le monde que vous êtes
meurtrier et un échange vous me rendez
le portefeuille que vous avez pris j'ai
pas pris de portefeuille
on peut faire tomber tous ensemble des
hauts mais il faut que tout le monde
collabore enseignant un papier que le
papier le papier de la communiste là
quel est le rapport
pourquoi
j'ai pas de portefeuille
de tous les autres
vidéos
je viens de trouver un portefeuille dans
mon double truc c'est vraiment moi ce
que je vous propose c'est je vous crois
on va partir du principe que je vous
crois en revanche vous allez retrouver
l'argent de Monsieur sens d'accord sinon
je dis à tout le monde que vous êtes
marseillais
parce que peut-être vous désirez donner
des informations encore tu sais quoi il
a il a pris l'argent il l'a mis dans sa
poche il a fait semblant de perdre son
portefeuille pour que tout le monde lui
rende encore plus d'argent
[Musique]
de discuter j'ai plus le Money je peux
voir au pocket
[Rires]
vous êtes fait piper
c'est la deuxième fois que vous parlez à
moi
vous m'accusez d'être un pickpocket
c'est la deuxième fois que vous pourrez
à quelqu'un vous croyez que j'ai besoin
de prendre de l'argent sur ce que vous
en avez jamais assez
jamais
décevez beaucoup dans l'attente de
trouver autre chose vous me passez de
sang et je dis à faire et que vous êtes
partis
j'ai hâte de rentrer chez moi
laissez la police faire son travail
est-ce que je peux avoir un billet pour
faire quoi
pour avancer dans la question
mais tout à l'heure en collaborait pas
c'était sous la menace là moi je veux
avancer je veux que des hautes
merci en preuve de bonne foi si vous me
soutenez contre déo je n'ai plus
l'utilité je l'ai récupéré
et on a du travail bonne chance
j'ai utilisé mon détecteur à ondes
antipod citronique sur alphabet et le
détecteur c'est complètement affolé
vraiment on est atteint des niveaux
absolument phénoménaux on est à neuf sur
10 sur l'échelle de malfaisance donc on
a bien affaire à un démon ici je pense
qu'il est possédé et donc je vais
essayer de l'exorciser avec de mon petit
crucifix qui est juste ici et de la
formule consacrée voilà
croise les doigts on touche du bois et
on y va
je veux les sous je suis à sec prochaine
ment
trop tard
[Musique]
il est temps de passer aux choses
sérieuses
depuis des siècles ma famille
utilise les poupées
je l'ai déjà utilisé pas mal de fois
[Musique]
l'objet de la victime
il est temps
de faire payer
ce petit [ __ ] de déo
[Musique]
si si comment coucou
le malin maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a les pupilles complètement dilaté ça
va
qu'est-ce qui se passe qui vous a tué
vous avez la pression c'est ça à force
de mentir et de manipuler monsieur c'est
quoi ce cinéma vous avez tué vous avouez
vous avez tué toutes les personnes vous
allez tuer monsieur chou entier mais
embarquez-le embarquez-le on le sait on
a trouvé le Beretta dans son bureau et
là il est en panique excuse-moi c'est
juste que je sais pas je me rappelle que
de me réveiller par terre là
vous venez de nous avouer devant à tous
que vous avez tué monsieur chou entier
avec un mobile en plus qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
un monsieur choix entier
avait des informations comme quoi
Monsieur déo soufflé souffrait de
troubles psychrètes psychiatrique pardon
psychiatrique
visiblement il avait des informations
ainsi que Maggie fait y elle même
est-ce que c'est vrai que vous souffrez
de troubles quotidien
de de folie et visiblement il voulait
l'attaquer en diffamation préventivement
écoutez moi c'est terminé les fouilles
vous ne bougez plus d'ici j'ai besoin de
contacter mes collègues pour savoir un
peu ce qu'il en est sur son dossier
médical et sur ce que je viens de lire
de la part de Monsieur fabette je sais
pas ce que vous avez vu du coup mais en
tout cas pendant je pensais que j'ai
quand même mourir ça se trouve vous avez
un deuxième meurtre ce soir parce que là
je vais victime même si j'ai dit je suis
l'assassin ça doit être un truc
inconscient quand on est en train tu
vois contre entre la vie et la mort ton
travail
il va bientôt être temps pour les
joueurs de faire les conclusions de leur
enquête pour information les empreintes
retrouvées sous le corps de chou entier
son véritablement celle de wildeo mais
c'est bien alphabet lassassin comment
c'est possible ça on va y revenir tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
il va falloir signer le petit document
c'est à dire
on va leur dire
il faudrait signer les accords de
YouTube
on n'a pas le choix monsieur
on va faire tomber des hauts on va
récupérer toutes les actions
[Musique]
sur le Beretta c'est ça qui va changer
la balance si on signe il fournissent
les preuves à la police et nous on sera
tranquille il dégage on récupère les
actions il y a pas de doute il y a pas
de danger on s'en fout c'est rien je
réfléchis mesdames et messieurs je vais
vous demander de tous vous réunir là où
je vous ai récupéré tout à l'heure 22h
et quelques sur les petits canapés faut
que je vous parle
[Musique]
j'ai bien reçu toutes vos notes mon
équipe est en train de les analyser mais
moi aussi je mené mon enquête
figurez-vous j'ai bien rigolé quand je
vous ai vu mentir trahir
ou ne pas comprendre
voici ce qui s'est passé nous avons
vérifié tous les faits voici enfin le
dénouement de toute cette aventure voici
pourquoi le démon ne pouvait pas
utiliser ses pouvoirs parce qu'il y
avait un ange dans la pièce et c'est
pour ça que alphabète fuyait toujours
Lucie appartement parce que en sa
présence il était jamais bien il était
toujours gêné mais le démon ne savait
pas que c'était un ange avant ce soir là
j'avais pas compris que c'était un démon
mais c'est bien grâce à ses pouvoirs de
démon qu'il avait réussi à implanter les
souvenirs des meurtres dans la tête de
wildeo et c'est grâce à son matériel
d'agent secret en tant que bien joué le
jour qu'il arrivait à déposer les
empreintes de wildeo sur les meurtres
que lui avait commis si vous voulez une
synthèse du dénouement ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le mot de la fin il apparaît
maintenant à l'écran vous pourrez faire
pause je vous le mettrai également dans
la description si vous voulez le
télécharger le lire tranquillement qui
explique exactement qui faisait quoi
d'une manière simple le Cluet de l'écart
d'or celui qui a eu le plus de bonnes
réponses sur son questionnaire et
attribué à quelqu'un que j'annoncerai
dans quelques secondes
puisque juste avant le meet tout d'or
c'est à dire les personnages qui ont le
mieux incarné leur rôle nous avons tout
d'abord monsieur sens c'est-à-dire Cyril
mithodore du club de licar 3
[Applaudissements]
je dois vous annoncer que notre grand
méchant a été cité plus de 3 fois dans
quel est le grand tueur de Youtube c'est
à dire que tu n'as pas gagné en tant que
tel j'en suis fort contrées mais pour
les semaines de préparation pour le rôle
que tu avais à tenir c'est à dire que
vous vous êtes trop billets vous aviez
un dossier long de joueurs en fait il
avait 4 5 fois la longueur de votre
dossier il connaît toute l'histoire par
cœur donc pour tout ça pour le rôle pour
la préparation pour le soutien de ce
grand méchant je te remets un méchant
d'or bien sûr merci beaucoup Franck
très beau méchant juste après toi nous
trouvons dans l'ordre je vais pas donner
les points il y a Cyril ensuite en
dernier en avant dernier du coup ensuite
execo Elisa et Pierre Elisa et Pierre
et ensuite avec 8 points nous trouvons
Charlie et 9 points Margaux
[Musique]
il y a un café délicat 3 d'or sera
Margot pour clôturer cette série bravo
[Applaudissements]
les joueurs s'en sont très bien sortis
alors évidemment moins que l'inspecteur
se sifflent parce qu'il avait les
réponses au départ ils ont bien tenu
leur rôle ils ont bien préparé leur
personnage ils ont vraiment bien joué le
jeu merci beaucoup à huit pour tout ça
je vous mets leur chaîne Youtube
respective dans la description n'hésitez
pas à aller dessus un gros merci à
Franck Brusset qui avait le dossier
personnage le plus complexe à apprendre
et à mémoriser il a vraiment bien fait
staff pour incarner son rôle merci
beaucoup merci à toute l'équipe de
sherlocksmann qui a préparé cette vidéo
particulièrement à Magda c'était son
projet à elle de mener à bien le club de
licar 3 alors évidemment elle était pas
toute seule il y a toute l'équipe
habituelle vous verrez leur nom au
générique et dans la description il y a
tous les grands professionnels avec qui
on est on est amis aujourd'hui qui
viennent nous prêter ma forte pour ce
genre de projet ils sont également
crédibles dans la description et dans le
générique de fin bref vous imaginez bien
ça se monte pas en claquant des doigts
comme ça ou alors faudra un nuage de
soufre avec un démon qui réalise les
vœux mais je tiens à mon foie merci à
vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner si vous n'êtes pas
encore si vous avez été désabonnés à
liker la vidéo à partager cette vidéo ça
a été un taf incroyable à mettre en
place mais mais quel kiffe c'est la fin
du concept des clés de l'Icare c'était
ça toujours été prévu pour être une
trilogie c'était fou de pouvoir faire le
premier épisode dans le château c'était
fou de faire le deuxième épisode après
la haut dans les branches c'était encore
plus dingue de mener à bien cette
version là de la Murder Party c'est une
idée dont j'avais parlé à Cyril qui
incarnait Adrien sens ce soir en 2016
Cyril et amixem à l'époque en 2016 on
échangeait des mails où je leur parlais
de ça que j'aimerais bien faire ce truc
là un jour on l'a fait pour vous et
grâce à vous merci pour les 2 millions
d'abonnés merci pour tout en fait voilà
on se voit peut-être à la sortie d'un de
mes spectacles prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt
[Musique]